it's freaking out I like make wonder
yeah I think it needs to see the light
not metaphorically alright so push it
back in this direction and hopefully it
flies out this way give us a more like
he's got to be able to see there's an
opening there and like line itself up
upon tear it which wrinkles and seeds on
the ground I'll leave that door open for
a second and let's leave leave the
hallway after all but the waves they
need to burst
he came out I'm loving this
this is Henry from minutephysics either
what happens if an immovable object
meets an unstoppable force is a popular
question on the Internet of course
relativity clearly tells us that there
is no such thing as an immovable object
here's why you make some my favorite
videos on YouTube so you have a you have
a master's degree in theoretical physics
right I do yes this guy okay Jake
YouTube thank you yeah he makes videos
where he draws about science stuff but
then he like kind of like augment them
with visual effects I think I know
exactly how you did that at least I
suspect what do you think it is I feel
like we have all those different arrows
linked to each other to the Sun in
position but lagging behind by some
amount of time yeah it'll move in and
after like point one two seconds it'll
move it will speak in its animation and
catch up you have a way of making these
really complex visual effects look so
natural when I was watching I found
myself realizing that you were
demonstrating the principles very very
well like I felt myself understanding
way better just because you're able to
show it happening the way it actually
happens you want to see that bird is
still there oh that's right there it's
going to sit there for hours until
nighttime or something they didn't like
when the place is quiet I'll try and
leave somehow Dizzy's the five the craft
which is nothing because there's no
activity hopefully we just go in to find
no bird rather than a dead bird or we
might be sent to invent a net gun option
B I guess claire-michel he would prefer
us to shoot indoors but Nick and I are
rebels and we're gonna go outside
that's right Carmichael can't stop me
you got a bomb you don't tell me what to
do who's ready for an unboxing alright
so here we go
Oh stream 900 portable SSD 960 gigabytes
wow this is a one terabyte portable SSD
I think says a us PC connection this is
a nice looking hard drive it's got
rubber bumpers over baby buggy bumpers
okay here oh yeah
solid-state drive 20:56 gigabyte SD card
I've not had a card that big ever in my
life I have this weird thing about
measuring the advancement of Technology
by whether or not I could eat it I can
now eat 256 gigabytes
ain't no thing some point hopefully I
eat like 10 terabytes that's what I know
I'll be really old you know be calories
on the gigabyte a million it's physics a
scren how many calories are in a
gigabyte 48 this is a 500 gigabyte hard
drive it's got little bumpers do it all
my data whatever he's like frisbee I
expand flash drives on-the-go mobile
backup this plugs into your phone I'm
going to take pictures on the highest
quality settings SanDisk big thank you
for sending us a box all these cool
things in it and guys we will tell you
our impressions and what we think of
this stuff as we use it in our studio I
hope it goes well we're sure we'll what
would you even call that a nano nano
watt it's like what I say in the video
is like a quintillion thow quadrillion
to a quadrillion to record Julian this
one is sponsored by folks that do
distributed computing you guys actually
might be really good candidates for this
what is there people who do research and
they need to computational power instead
of like just paying lots of money to
rent out supercomputers they have made
like a really really easy to install
application that you can just install on
your own computer and when you're not
using your computer you make your
processor and your GPU available for
them to do science research on here
donating like your electricity bill to
and you're like unused CPU time and GPU
time okay to scientific research that's
really cool the way it works is like if
a computer finds a signal it's also
checked by other computers and whether
they will tell you like that your
computer was involved in finding this
they want to basically get people like
you guys
and everyone who's watching to install
this software on your computer it's
called boink and then the particular
project that I did this video on is
called Einstein at home and it's
searching for neutron stars super fast
spinning neutron stars in the
gravitational wave data but there's a
whole bunch of other projects on the
link basically you install this one
boink thing uh-huh and then you can sign
up for different projects so I see
someone you can choose what research
compare does yeah so I have it set up to
do this gravitational wave one but
there's a number of other things some of
them are like biological like genome
searching okay or analysis and other
there's other physics projects that's
super cool take that bird Stiller or you
think it escaped with that open door I
hope I don't a dead bird to clean up in
the corner of the room I don't see it
birdie
I think it's car yeah the bird is smart
and can figure it out after all huh what
do we got
got a little portable 500 gigabyte hard
drive it's for this 2 terabyte one well
we also got a 1 terabyte hard drive I'll
make up for it last but not least this
is my Carmichael the most happy Oh 256
gigabyte 90 by 95 read and write feed
this will be great for the next studio
camera for the second channel that will
eventually get one day